welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me Josh Smith and stay we're
joined by the intergalactic Queen
herself days riffing how are you great
thanks I'm feeling better now you call
me a clue what do you think you've
learned about yourself through going on
this amazing journey with cell Wars I've
learned that I'm a sticker I stick it
things yeah and when things are tough
and I've also learned that I have a
really good um I don't have a good poker
face for when like I'm emotional but
when I'm absolutely terrified doing a
stunt I've learned that I have quite a
calm face we were doing something in the
desert that was literally giving me a
panic attack and our stunt coordinator
Eunice who said I was like hey Gigi
she's a scout sorry anyone from the book
and later on I said Eunice that was
terrifying she's like yeah so you sorry
like you didn't see me so I learnt that
I have a good calm how do you lean into
your own mental strength in those tough
moments I probably more leans into the
people around me because you just have
to trust that you're if your life is in
someone else's hands they're gonna keep
you safe
oh so it's a lot of trust telling
yourself it's gonna be okay and also
telling yourself if something does
happen that it it's the right thing hmm
because it's I guess like as well being
in as part of Star Wars it's like the
most intense thing on the planet to be
doing yeah very intense have you looked
after your own mental well-being while
having this level of insane scrutiny on
annual munch therapy a bit which was
great because a lot of it was about
feeling out of control because I'm quite
controlling in that I like to know
what's going on and suddenly you're in a
situation where you have no idea what's
going on you don't know if people are
gonna look at you don't know if people
are gonna be somewhere like you don't
know to what extent you know your day is
it gonna go and then in general doing
stuff like if I don't want to go out I
won't go out if I want to see people I
won't see people facial massage one of
the things that keep you feeling good
what do you think you learn about
yourself the most from going to therapy
would you say
weirdly that I think and a lot of people
have that when you have a lot of like
stress or drama
I remember thinking what do you fill
that space with if you deal with the
drama and the stress and she was like
well you the therapist was like well you
did it with good things and I was like
oh because I think a lot of people
assume you have to feel stress with
stress but you don't like deal with the
stress and then fill it with good stuff
yeah that PMA man show can get free
sometimes as well it's also like as well
I guess is it learning at your your own
Ally as well yeah and also learning that
you're the only person that is
experiencing your life yourself so if
you're not having a good time what is
the point like you have to almost fake
it till you make it huh force yourself
to have a good time and then eventually
you'll be like oh yeah okay this is
quite enjoy and also like I guess
playing such a strong character as well
gives you another level of faith in
yourself as well have you found that I
think it's less playing her and more
being surrounded by very talented people
that have worked with a lot of people
that are like oh yeah I'll listen to
what you have to say sure you have an
idea let's try it so when people are
giving you this space to have ideas
you're like oh yeah maybe I am like
smart and maybe I am talented all of
those things that for the most part
people zone to self-doubt if you had a
turning point a specific turning point
in your self-doubt journey yeah I took
six months off before we did this one
and it was just a good time to be like
yes it's all good I'm supposed to be
here which is why I think I had the best
experience for my subscribe or cuz I
felt the most confidence and I felt even
though it's very difficult I felt the
most at ease within myself and as well
like I think it's so great that you're
playing this very strong and we talked
about strong for you my character all
the time but also find me a woman who
isn't strong right like come on
we give birth yeah exactly that's a lot
but as well like it's such a great role
for having a strong body image as well I
think for to show young women that as
well that you can like strong it's not
that being skinny what's like what's
been your own journey with body image
for you oh I think I didn't really have
a thing about body image and then you
sort of realized that it's you know it's
more of an issue than I sort of like a
friend of mine had a really bad eating
disorder at school and then I was sort
of more aware of like the need that
people have to look like something that
they're not but when I started training
with a new company that I trained with
now it's all about strength and mobility
and stability and I didn't get ill
during filming and I didn't get injured
so for me now that's the most important
thing of anything when you feel good if
you're doing stuff yeah if you don't
want to run don't run like if you don't
want to go and sweat for an hour every
day don't do it just do stuff that makes
you feel good and work on yourself as
well right yeah because it's also like
if you're jealous person you can work on
that smother it with love you're an
angry person smother it with love what
do you think has been the piece of
advice that's got you through those
moments where you've doubted yourself
it's that one piece of advice or someone
you turn to who's really changed you in
that sentence oh I think my parents have
always said that I'm brave because I'm
scared of things but I do it anyway so I
guess it's that because I'm yeah for the
most part ultimately you have to feel
that you can do it and want to do it
there's a time when you've leaned into
that bravery and it said to me like
empowered ta I mean I had to do scuba
diving training and I was having a total
panic surf at the bottom of the thing
and I had to think myself it's okay
you're here there's nothing you can do
except breathing big feet breathe calm
well I think you're amazing thank you
and it's so great you've been on this
incredible journey thank you and it's
ending now how do you feel about that
feels I currently just feel very tired
and like I'm so ready for Christmas yeah
and to go home and see my family
yeah the way only saw last night for a
few hours and it was sort of diluted
with a lot of other people and and then
I think I'm mid-january like
this is weird yeah what's going on what
do you think I'm gonna do to fill that
void hopefully find another job I've
been searching I think you're gonna find
it babe like please I'm gonna employ me
and what else am I gonna do just chill
yeah yeah the manifest manifest at job
babes yeah I'm gonna write some stuff
down I wanted a what do I know to you
amazing well congrats thank you
keeps laying air thank you see you in
another intern amis lamer slaves yeah
thanks for joining us for another
empowering edition of glamour unfiltered
faced by meet Josh Smith and make sure
you subscribe to the glam at UK channels
now for more content such as this and we
see you in two weeks the next session of
glamour unfiltered
[Music]
you